[Music]
so thanks for coming into the session I
want to give you a quick overview of
what we're going to talk about in this
session so for the people in the room
who are new to Claude Firestone I'm
gonna give you an introduction on what
it gives you why we built the particular
product and then I'm gonna jump into
what's new so we've got a couple of
exciting announcements of new features
and functionality we're launching for
firestore so we'll cover that then we'll
go through some common architectures
that we've seen during our beta program
from actual customers who are using the
product some of them who are in the room
today and then Cathy will come back on
talk about how Google itself is using
cloud firestore for an application you
might all be familiar with and then give
a quick demo and look at some of the
code behind that demo and then I'll come
back on we'll talk a little bit about
scaling tips and then we'll probably do
a Q&A if we have enough time at the end
so to start let me talk a little bit
about what this session is really about
it's really about helping you understand
how to build scalable apps using GCP and
firebase and in particular using the
cloud firestore database just to kick
things up can I find out in this room
who has used firebase real time database
before and who has used cloud datastore
before and who has already played with
cloud via store I might need to get some
of you to come do the presentation it's
actually a lot of people in here that's
awesome so I want to start by painting a
picture or an architecture of something
that I would have used to have done
let's say you're in a company and you're
building a new mobile web application
how would you go about building that in
a traditional way you would start off
with a web server for your static
content then you might have a dedicated
application server for the dynamic
content that's changing and mutating as
your users are using it you probably
have a database server running somewhere
running on some sort of
system storage then you're probably
thinking about adding in replication so
you can do maintenance without having to
bring everything down maybe give
yourself some high availability
capabilities it's not too hard to add
and then as your app starts to get more
successful you're probably thinking
about disaster recovery and how would
you build that so now you're worrying
about a standby data center you've got
VPNs and Carriere interconnect by that
you're building at this point you've got
some pretty heavy infrastructure that
you built and you've got full-time
people maintaining that infrastructure
well what we want to do is give you
tooling that
abstracts that away and gives you
something where you can focus on just
the app that you're writing so with
cloud firestore and some of our products
that we have in the firebase platform we
can simplify that final architecture
that I showed you with a very simple
setup you can use cloud firestore
directly from your devices and you can
use via base hosting for this torreón
and serving the static content and you
can do use firebase off to give you that
secure interface into it and then
finally you can use cloud functions to
expand into the many other tools that we
have within GCP so when we built cloud
Firestone we really believe in giving
tooling so that small teams can
accomplish big things and by providing
those small team with powerful yet
simple tools that get out of the way we
can give them a foundation for success
lastly we want to make sure this tooling
is available everywhere so let's start
off with some of the basics behind
firestorm so we have firebase SDKs that
we've integrated with to give you Native
Client libraries on iOS web and Android
we integrate with firebase
authentication to handle the
authentication into the server we have a
declarative security rules language to
allow you to control access to your data
based on not just the properties of the
signed-in user but also the information
in its database itself we give you cloud
functions to integrate into the rest of
the platform
and we also use bio-based hosting as a
convenient way to serve up content now
it's City it is expected in apps today
that they would just work across mobile
and web you may not have intended this
to happen but it's a basic expectation
most people have today that they can
pick up their phone and continue using
what they were using on the web and
sometimes even use both of them at the
same time there's a further expectation
which perhaps some people in the
audience have discovered today that
network connectivity is not always
available there are environments even in
our hyper-connected world where you need
to have offline capabilities in your app
and we'll build a lot of tooling around
this to make it simple to enable these
use cases in your application further
than that we know people are building
some very complex applications on our
tooling so we have a full suite of
server client libraries including
c-sharp Go Java Python PHP these
particular tools allow you to use our
server list database in a way that is
truly scalable regardless of what
architecture you want to use we have got
a multi region replicated database to
make sure it's always reliable and
available for you and I'll talk a little
bit about that in a second so just to
finish off the actual database itself in
this quick intro I want to talk about
how the data is structured so we spent a
lot of time with the real-time database
people to understand how people are
using that data and what ways they want
to naturally use it and for cloud
firestore we're using a collection and
document model that allows you to store
related data together in a semi
structured fashion so let's quickly talk
about what is new and these are all
coming shortly studying in August and
then rolling out through 2019 so the
first one that I want to talk about
cloud fire story is going to have a lot
of new locations launched so currently
we have a multi region location in the
US and starting next month we're going
to gradually roll out
full suite of locations that you see
here whether it's in the Americas Europe
or Asia Pacific you're going to be able
to locate your database and your data
closest to where your particular user
base is we are also announcing and this
is of interest to the cloud datastore
customers in the room the cloud
firestore is now going to support
datastore mode cloud file store is
designed as the third generation of
cloud datastore and it's going to
support all the existing api's and
client libraries that you use today
we are going to seamlessly upgrade every
one so you don't need to change your
code and you don't need to worry about
downtime to get the properties that we
have in this new system some of those
properties I will go into in a second
but they include things like being
strongly consistent for all queries and
having a five nines availability essay
once we get to GA the beta for this new
mode starts in August so you're probably
asking what's the catch so let me talk
about a couple of the things that we're
removing in datastore mode for cloud
datastore users the first thing that
we're removing is the entity group
restrictions you have today so no longer
will you be limited to one write per
second per entity group to get strongly
consistent data so hopefully this is a
good thing we've removed for you the
second one is you no longer need to use
ancestor queries to have strong
consistency all queries across cloud
datastore when you're using cloud
firestore in the new datastore mode will
be strongly consistent and the last
thing we're removing is the 25 entity
group limit for transactions doesn't
matter how many entity groups you use in
cloud datastore we will support the
transactions for it just want to quickly
touch on the upgrade because I know a
lot of you who have got cloud datastore
databases are wondering how this was
going to happen so we are doing the
upgrade for you the Google engineering
team is going to be live migrating the
information from cloud datastore to
datastore mode without any downtime we
will send announcements out about this
to our user base in
coming weeks there is no action required
on your behalf we are going to handle
everything there are no code changes
that you need to do and all the existing
functionality api's and client libraries
you use will still work if you want to
play with it early you can create new
databases during our beta period and
once we get to GA we will start
upgrading so you just wanted to quickly
point out some of the differences in
case you're wondering when you would use
datastore mode the new mode we're
announcing today and native mode which
is the existing mode cloud via store
users have been using in beta there's a
couple of minor terminology differences
between them datastore mode is designed
as that server-side database and cloud
the native mode is designed as your
back-end as a service for your mobile
web and IOT applications when you think
about datastore think about a no sequel
database that scales from zero to a
million writes a second when you think
about native mode think about it back
end as a service it scales from zero to
a million concurrent connections from
your devices we've also just published
our draft SLA so this is the SLA that
will go into effect once we get to GA
for our multi region locations it's five
nines of availability and for our
regional locations it's four nines of
availability this system is designed to
make sure your app is up and running
when you need it in August we are also
releasing managed exports for native
mode so this will allow you to take a
full export of your data into GCS and
import it back into your project if you
need to recover some of that data or
perhaps import it into another project a
dev or a QA environment you can also
take these exports and import them into
bigquery so you can use a full sequel
language to do ad hoc reporting against
that data we have also added the data
viewer for native mode into GCPs console
so starting in August you will see a new
firestore tab where you can see our live
updating UI to manipulate and query
against your data we are also adding a
new set of functionality around managing
your indexes so for those who haven't
used cloud firestore before we
automatically index all your fields in
your document sometimes you want more
control over that and so we've got a new
system that allows you to selectively
turn on and off particular types of
indexes for your document
for those people who have got sharpeye
as you may have seen a new mode a new
indexing mode down the bottom chord
array contains so cloud firestore will
now be able to do containment queries
against the race and I just saw a little
fist bump so that's a good sign so now I
want to talk about some of the common
architectures I've seen with customers
who have been using cloud firestore
successfully the first one I want to
talk about is guesswork guesswork is a
machine learning startup for helping
ecommerce companies in emerging markets
they recommend new products for
first-time buyers on their side when a
new user arrives on the site guess where
it collects a whole bunch of data points
about that user where they're coming
from did they come from an email
campaign or a fashion website and
including other things like the
geographic region and the device type
they then come up with a recommendation
based on this user and the data can take
a couple of paths to get back to the
user
so let's have a quick look at one of the
examples they did with a company called
Zalora in Southeast Asia to bring better
ecommerce recommendations to their
customers so to start with they're using
the Google tag manager you may be
familiar with this if you're using
firebase analytics with the cloud
firestore SDK to write information back
into cloud firestore about the user who
visited the site this centric is a
couple of different data pipelines to
process this data
the first one is triggering a cloud
function that then uses
then inserts the data into bigquery this
makes the whole data set available to
the recommendation engine to do
processing the second pipeline that they
get that gets kicked off with a cloud
function is using the cloud vision API
to process image now this I think is
really interesting because guesswork
deals with so many different languages
out there they found it more reliable to
use the vision API across the image of
the product to get metadata back then
relying upon the text metadata and
trying to understand and process all the
different variations of language so they
get better more consistent results by
processing the image of the product the
recommendation then uses this
information to take two paths the first
one is for anonymous users they write
the recommendation back into firestore
which gives a real-time update out to
the client for that user for registered
users they can send a periodic email
with the recommendations to them so here
is the whole architecture on a single
slide it's very simple but very powerful
and this architecture has allowed them
to move very quickly and make changes so
they can a be test different algorithms
to improve their recommendations and
improve obviously their revenue so one
of the things that I really love about
this example is guesswork is a company
of three people that they bootstrapped
using this technology and they now serve
a hundred million users so three people
managed to bootstrap a successful
company to serve a hundred million users
using this tech that's all about the
small teams able to do big things now
this is another example I love pork and
dynamics they're probably one of the
most interesting meetings I've been on
you see some force plates on here we had
a video conference with them and they
were in the back of the room jumping up
down doing counter-movement jumps on
plates it's probably one of the most
energetic meetings I've had so hokum
dynamics is a sports performance company
focused on providing cutting-edge
technology in both software and hardware
for athletic teams they optimize
athletic performance by analyzing the
information from these four place using
things like counter movement jumps an
isometric tests and so let's have a
quick look at their architecture which
is very simple and there's one little
bit I'll add in a minute but it really
is this simple form so they've got force
plates that they give out two teams that
at a very fine grain level measure the
force of the movements of the athletes
this information is then wirelessly
transmitted to the mobile apps whether
it's a phone or a tablet that Hawken
dynamics has these apps work offline
because not all the locations where
they're doing these testing doing this
test has network connectivity on the app
they can quickly review the raw data
that the false places produce and maybe
get the athletes to repeat the test or
look for something new when they are
connected they use firebase off to
authenticate in and sync this
information into cloud firestore which
once again kicks off cloud functions to
do the processing on the raw data to
pull out moving averages and other
information that then they can display
in more depth in their mobile web
application so when they are online all
of these are kept closely in sync with
each other so you can see in real time
what the results are
they sent me a copy of their data model
so we could have a quick look and see
how they structure it and this uses some
of the collection and document hierarchy
that we provide within cloud via store
so they have an overall collection
called teams where all of the sports
teams they have lived within and they
have a document that just has some basic
information about that team under the
team document each team has a set of
data the settings for how they want to
configure displays and the test that
they have the actual raw data that gets
synced from the false plates the test
which is a compute
result that comes from cloud functions
and the different groups that different
athletes within those players on that
team exist so let's talk about the
athletes which has a document that
outlines a bunch of information about
when they were tested using arrays what
different groups they're in what their
weight is etc and then under that is
that computed average Doc's so a player
can go in and look at their performance
over time and how they're improving
based on different training schedules so
with that I want to hand it back to
Kathy to talk about how Google has been
using cloud fire still thanks Dan so if
you're looking at this screenshot this
page is probably one that you've
actually know and have already
interacted with it's the Google cloud
next conference website our developer
friends at the nerdery actually built
the web and mobile apps for this event
using cloud firestore they like many
developers often do work with existing
systems and storage solutions rather
than building from the ground up even so
cloud fire store can still work well in
this case we'll first take a look at
some of their actual data in fire store
to give an example of how some
application data can be laid out and
then we'll zoom to the whole system this
is a view of the fire stored data viewer
in the firebase web console and you can
see there are top-level collections for
in this case events with documents for
the cloud next events in San Francisco
Tokyo and London and the latter two are
coming up in the fall it's a flexible
data model so your application can write
whatever you need in this case there's
some metadata fields on the individual
days of this event we also have some
English language sub collections of all
the content that you'll see on the
conference site such as the home page
and marketing copy the event sponsors
and the filters that you use to narrow
down your view of the day's programming
lastly here are the sessions in a sub
collection with documents for every one
of the general sessions that you might
attend including the one we're sitting
in right now
there's the document with a list of
labels for the topics a room capacity
and as you might imagine if a the size
of the attendee list for a session
reaches the room capacity then the
application logic will set the can
reserve boolean fields to false so now
that you've seen a view of some of the
data how do the developers use cloud
firestore to improve on the app from
prior years nerdery already works with
an existing third-party SAS provider
that specializes in event management so
they store the all the conference data
such as sessions speakers registrants
rooms and map data they can read
directly from here but since there's no
event driven model for responding to
changes in your data the app pulls this
information on the order of many minutes
which in the past has led to registrants
quickly filling up sessions on the day
of and a slight delay in showing that
status now nerdery copies all of their
event data into cloud firestore which
they use as a single source of truth for
all apps to read from they also wrote a
custom API served on Google App Engine
which accepts writes from clients such
as a user bookmarking a talk and handles
transactions to the third party system
then fires the clients read directly
from fire store to display all the data
that you actually see here's a view of
the whole system and we can
contextualize it with an interaction
that you've probably already had when
you first view the conference website it
loads all the session and information on
partners and stuff from fire store as
well as images and other static assets
from Google Cloud Storage then when you
want to take an action like bookmarking
a panel discussion you'll log in using
either your Google account or email
address and the apps use firebase off to
authenticate you then when you register
for a session such as this one the app
makes an API call out to the third-party
system to update the logged in users set
of reserved events but it also
immediately writes that session metadata
back to firestore this eliminates having
to pull on such an availability so that
as soon as an event actually fills up
its status will be displayed as full to
all the apps so thanks to the folks over
at nerdery for building the apps that
we're all using this week now we want to
show you the scalability and ease of use
of cloud firestore we have a demo that
illustrates how a large number of
concurrently connected devices can
receive updates from and write updates
to firestore this will be visualized
shortly in a google colored fire store
logo display with pixels that represent
the end-user devices in each of four
colored quadrants then to reflect the
quadrants is updated colors in real time
we use one of the major features of fire
store which is the ability to listen for
changes at any node in your data
hierarchy so you'll see pixels updating
their color as new color values are
written to the documents for each
quadrant if you want to see this
visualization please visit fire pixels
app and also hold up your device to us
when it's loaded I will do this as well
so you should see something kind of like
this
awesome seeing a few following along
yeah thanks
can we also transition to the demo
screen I mean here what we're seeing is
that we imitate devices which are our
clients with nodejs processes and every
simulated device gets assigned a pixel
in this entire grid totaling $40,000
40,000
of pixels change color is done by
writing a new value to the color field
in a document for each quadrant then we
have set up the clients to listen on the
input document for each quadrant and
when it gets written they'll read the
new color from the data snapshot and
write it back to the pixel document in
fire store as the pixels color values
are written you'll then see their
corresponding pixels in the display
change color currently you're seeing
some of these color changes every
handful of seconds as there are some
automatic changes happening as well as
people probably playing with a demo in
the storage showcase booth which is on
the ground floor of this building so we
can also actually edit this or make the
pixels and quadrants change colors
ourselves by writing the data and in
order to do that let's actually bring up
the cloud console so here's a view of
the cloud console wherein we've
navigated to the firestore data viewer
and over here you can see the three
collections that we have for the many
devices these are numbered
we have as many simulated devices as
there are total spots with an X and y
coordinate per quadrant we have pixels
that get assigned to to each device and
each pixel has is named for its X and y
coordinate has a color which matches the
color of the input document for the
quadrant as well as a partition that's
used to parallel eyes and speed up the
UI updates and an updated timestamp and
we can look at the input collection so
here are the documents 0 through 3 for
all four quadrants in the logo with a
color that we can actually set so right
now the green this quadrant 0 is green
although this something about doing
demos
and I check my phone real quick to see
if it's updated let's see what happens
when we write this value directly in the
data viewer where you can view real-time
updates and modify your data
sorry for the hiccup so in this case we
actually if you're looking at it on your
phone you should see that some of the
quadrants have pixels that are mixed
colors or individual pixels that aren't
all the same color in the quadrant and
usually these are represent the devices
seeing that a new value has been written
for the color for that quadrant and then
the clients will asynchronously pick up
that update write their color back and
this then gets updated in the UI which
is how you see different pixels trickle
into the new color that they should be
this will be going on and you can
actually play with this demo on a few
real device mobile devices at the
storage showcase booth one thing we
should be able to see in the data viewer
is that if you change the value of the
input here the pixels should reflect
their respective quadrant so we're
because it has a listener on the input
field so here say we set the input to
blue then we go over to the pixels and
it's now been updated whereas it was red
before if you had noticed that we change
this to green and then these values
should have our updating in real time in
the data viewer and one other thing of
interest especially for people who are
writing applications that use more
complex queries and therefore need index
to configure indexes to support those
queries you can navigate over to the
indexes section and here we have in our
case one composite index defined on the
pixels collection and two fields which
enables a query used to load the UI
and this is the new feature under single
field indexes where each project is
automatically configured to have all of
their fields indexed in ascending
descending an array contains modes but
since it since you want to as a general
pattern avoid indexing monotonically
increasing or decreasing values in this
case we have disabled indexing on the
fields that represent time stamps last
updated time stamps to make sure that
our app keeps performing smoothly can we
transition back to the slides as an
overview of how this app is set up we
have the devices simulated as nodejs
processes running in kubernetes pods
with separate pods for each quadrant
each of those processes then sets up
many pixels each associated with a
device and as well as setting up
listeners on the firestore input
document that has the color per quadrant
we can change the colors in the display
either using a controller app that you
can see it'll be on a pixel phone at the
demo downstairs or via just changing the
data directly in the cloud console which
we just did this rights to fire store
which triggers more updates for each
pixel document then with thousands of
pixels updating at once we used a go-go
Lang back-end app to send the new colors
to the fire store logo display using
WebSockets which for us is a workaround
so that the browser doesn't try to
process thousands of updates at once but
you can see that fire store does scale
to handle many reads and writes in real
time to show this a little more
concretely here's a code snippet using a
key feature of fire store which is the
real-time updates we have the at the top
references to to the database and each
of the collections in it and in the in
our knit function we actually call this
setup listener for each spot this is per
process that after we've spawned many we
set up a listener on the input document
per each of the four areas such that
when that gets written we invoke our
callback that grabs the data snapshot
and writes the new color value to the
pixel document which then gets rendered
in the UI so there you have it we are
using fire store to sync app state in
real time and it scales up to tens of
thousands of concurrently connected
devices and you can have ultimately
millions of clients using your app now
we'll hand it back to Dan to wrap up
with some considerations to keep in mind
as you build and grow your fire store
apps thanks Kathy so I want to just run
through a couple of quick points to keep
in mind when you're building larger apps
before we go into QA
and I will not try to do any demo on
conference Wi-Fi so the first thing to
remember as we're learning we've used a
lot of customer applications that are
now part of our test suite and stress
tests in particular so one thing to
consider when writing your application
is how do you write scale and so a
couple of guidelines that we have the
first is for each individual document
try to keep the sustained update rate to
once per second so we do multi region
replication across data centers that
have geographically dispersed so there
is some time of speed-of-light
considerations as part of that you can
of course burst higher but if you do a
sustained
like 30 a second for a long period of
time eventually your app will start to
get a lot slower the other one which
Kathy mentioned with monotonically
increasing and decreasing values is keep
the rights of those types of data to
around 500 per second when our system
splits we do horizontal key ranges and
we split on either side to have more
service take care of that load when
you're just appending data to the end of
say indexes or primary keys or pre
pending data then all the load ends up
on one side of the split so we'll only
ever have one server taking care of that
load for you when you're using the
native mode we support at the moment
during beta 10000 writes per second when
you're in data store mode we support up
to a million writes per second and this
is around the real-time notification
system and whether that's turned on or
off when you're ramping up your traffic
so if you've got large events that are
happening we have a rule that we call
the 555 rule which is starting off at
500 writes per second and growing at 50%
every 5 minutes and for read think about
10x that the other thing that you should
consider is how your concurrent
connections work so as your user base
scales how are the number of concurrent
connections that you have from your
client libraries going to scale so as a
general rule we support up to 1 million
concurrent connections when you're doing
one update per second per key night per
connections that's a million updates a
second across all your devices to put
that in context a million concurrent
users is something like 10 to 14 million
daily active users depending on the
makeup of your application the other
thing to just keep in mind is how much
data you're pushing out to your clients
and generally it's about 10 megabytes
per second across that list of clients
[Music]